se refleja en los objetos y produce ecos en el entorno,
los murciélagos escuchan esos ecos
y esa información la transforman en una imagen acústica.
Esto les permite orientarse en completa oscuridad.
De hecho, los murciélagos se ven raros. Nosotros somos humanos.
Somos una especie visual. Cuando los científicos descubrieron
que los murciélagos en realidad usaban el sonido para volar,
orientarse y moverse en la noche, no lo creímos.
Durante cien años y a pesar de lo que mostraba la evidencia
sobre lo que hacían, no lo creímos.
Si uno mira a un murciélago parece un poco extraterrestre.
De hecho, Thomas Nagel, un filósofo famoso
dijo una vez que "para experimentar una forma de vida extraterrestre
en este planeta, basta con encerrarse en un cuarto oscuro
con un murciélago que esté volando y usando la ecolocalización".
Y si vemos las verdaderas características físicas
en la cara de este hermoso "murciélago herradura",
apreciamos que muchas de ellas están destinadas
a emitir un sonido y percibirlo.
Orejas muy grandes, nariz extraña lanceolada, pero ojos muy pequeños.
Así que si miramos de nuevo a un murciélago, nos damos cuenta
de que el sonido es muy importante para su supervivencia.
La mayoría de los murciélagos se parecen al anterior.
Aunque hay un grupo que no usa la ecolocalización.
No perciben su entorno utilizando el sonido.
Este grupo es el de los murciélagos zorros.
Si alguien ha tenido la buena suerte de estar en Australia,
los habrá visto en el Jardín Botánico de Sidney,
y si les miras la cara, observarás que tienen
ojos mucho más grandes y orejas mucho más pequeñas.
Así que hay una gran variación entre los murciélagos
en cuanto a su habilidad para usar la percepción sensorial.
Ahora esto va a ser importante para lo que les
voy a decir más adelante en esta charla.
Ahora, si la idea de murciélagos en tu campanario te aterroriza,
y sé que alguna gente probablemente se siente un poco mal
viendo imágenes muy grandes de murciélagos,
probablemente no sea tan sorprendente,
porque aquí en la cultura Occidental,
los murciélagos han sido demonizados.
Realmente, desde luego el famoso libro de "Drácula",
escrito por un compatriota del norte de Dublín, Bram Stoker,
probablemente sea el principal responsable de esto.
De todas formas, también creo que tiene que ver con el hecho
de que los murciélagos salen por la noche, y nosotros
realmente no los entendemos. Estamos un poco asustados por las cosas
que perciben al mundo ligeramente diferente a nosotros.
A los murciélagos generalmente se los asocia con eventos malvados
son agresores en películas de terror,
como la famosa "Nightwing"
también, si se ponen a pensar, los demonios
siempre tienen alas de murciélago, mientras que
los ángeles normalmente tienen alas de pájaro
ahora, esta es la sociedad occidental, y lo que espero hacer hoy
es convencerlos de la cultura tradicional china,
que percibe a los murciélagos como
criaturas que traen buena suerte y, de hecho, si entras
a una casa china, tal vez veas una imagen como esta.
Esto es considerado las 5 bendiciones.
La palabra china para "murciélago" suena como la palabra china
para "felicidad", y ellos creen que los murciélagos
traen riqueza, salud, longevidad, virtud y serenidad.
y de hecho, en esta imagen, tienen una foto de longevidad
rodeada por 5 murciélagos.
Lo que quiero hacer esta noche es hablarles
y enseñarles que al menos 3 de estas bendiciones
son definitivamente representadas por un murciélago, y que si los estudiamos
estaremos cerca de alcanzar cada una de estas bendiciones
Bueno, riqueza... ¿cómo un murciélago nos puede dar riqueza?
Como dije antes, los murciélagos son esenciales para que
nuestros ecosistemas funcionen correctamente. ¿Por qué?
Los murciélagos tropicales son los mayores polinizadores de muchas plantas.
También comen fruta y dispersan las semillas
de estas frutas. Los murciélagos son responsables de polinizar
la planta de tequila, y esta es una industria multimillonaria
en México. Entonces, los necesitamos
para que nuestros ecosistemas funcionen bien.
Sin ellos, sería un problema.
Pero la mayoría de los murciélagos son depredadores de insectos.
Se estima que una colonia pequeña de grandes murciélagos
pardos en EUA, comerá
más de un millón de insectos al año,
y actualmente en Estados Unidos
los murciélagos están amenazados por una enfermedad llamada el síndrome de la nariz blanca.
Está avanzando lentamente a través de EUA y eliminando
poblaciones de murciélagos y científicos han estimado
que 1300 toneladas métricas de insectos por año están
quedando en el ecosistema a causa de la perdida de murciélagos.
Los murciélagos también son amenazados en EUA
por su atracción a los parques eólicos. Otra vez,
los murciélagos se están viendo como un problema.
Ellos van a... están muy amenazados
en los Estados Unidos nada más.
Ahora, ¿cómo nos puede ayudar esto?
Bueno, ha sido calculado que si eliminamos a los murciélagos
de la ecuación, vamos a tener que usar
insecticidas para eliminar todas esas pestes de insectos
que se comen nuestros productos agrícolas.
Y por un año (solo en EUA) se estima
que va a costar USD 22 000 millones,
si eliminamos a los murciélagos. Entonces, los murciélagos sí nos dan riqueza.
Mantienen la salud de nuestro ecosistema,
y nos ahorran dinero.
Otra vez, esa es la primera bendición. Los murciélagos
son importantes para nuestro ecosistema.
¿Qué pasa con la segunda? ¿Qué pasa con la salud?
Adentro de cada célula de tu cuerpo está tu genoma.
Tu genoma está compuesto por tu ADN,
los códigos ADN para construir las proteínas que te permiten funcionar
e interactuar y ser como eres.
Ahora con los nuevos avances modernos de tecnología molecular,
es posible determinar la secuencia de nuestro propio genoma
en un tiempo breve y a un costo muy, muy reducido.
Ahora que hemos estado haciendo esto, nos damos cuenta
de que hay variaciones en nuestro genoma.
Quiero que vean a la persona al lado de Uds..
Solo una mirada rápida. Y lo que tenemos que observar
es que de cada 300 pares de bases en el ADN, tu eres apenas diferente.
Y uno de los desafíos más grandes ahora
en la medicina molecular moderna es descubrir
si esta variación te hace más sensible a enfermedades
o solo te hace diferente.
Otra vez, ¿qué significa esto? ¿qué significa esta variación?
Si queremos sacar provecho de los nuevos datos
moleculares e información genética personalizada
que está saliendo en línea, que vamos a poder tener
en los próximos años, tenemos que poder diferenciar
estas dos cosas. Entonces, ¿cómo hacemos esto?
Bueno, yo creo que solo tenemos que observar los experimentos de la naturaleza.
Entonces, a través de la selección natural, a través del tiempo,
mutaciones, variaciones que interrumpen la función de una proteína
no van a ser toleradas.
La evolución actúa como un cedazo. Deja afuera las variaciones malas.
Entonces, si observas la misma región
de un genoma en muchos mamíferos que han estado
evolutivamente distantes y que también son
ecológicamente diferentes, vas a tener
un mejor entendimiento de cuál es la evolución anterior de ese lugar,
es decir, si es importante para que el mamífero funcione,
para su supervivencia, será lo mismo
en todos los diferentes linajes, especies, taxones.
Entonces, si hiciéramos esto,
lo que necesitamos hacer es decodificar esa región
en todos los mamíferos diferentes y ver
si es igual o diferente. Entonces si es igual
eso indica que ese lugar es importante para una función
entonces una mutación de una enfermedad debería caer en ese lugar.
Entonces en este caso, si todos los mamíferos que analizamos
tienen un genoma amarillo en ese lugar,
probablemente sugiere que el morado es malo.
Esto podría ser más poderoso todavía si observaras
mamíferos que están haciendo las cosas un poco diferente.
Digamos, por ejemplo, la región del gen
que estuve viendo era una región que es importante para la visión.
Si observamos esa región en mamíferos que no ven bien,
como los murciélagos, y encontramos que esos murciélagos que no ven tan bien
tienen el tipo morado, deduciremos que probablemente sea esto
lo que está causando la enfermedad.
Entonces en mi laboratorio, hemos usado murciélagos para analizar
dos tipos diferentes de enfermedades de los sentidos.
Estamos estudiando la ceguera. ¿Por qué harías esto?
314 millones de personas tienen problemas de la vista
y 45 millones de estas son ciegas. Entonces la ceguera es un gran problema,
y muchos de estos problemas de ceguera son hereditarios
entonces queremos entender mejor
qué mutaciones en el gen están causando la enfermedad.
También observamos la sordera. Uno de cada 1000
recién nacidos son sordos, y cuando cumplamos 80,
más de la mitad de nosotros va a tener problemas de audición.
Otra vez, hay muchas causas genéticas para esto.
Entonces lo que hemos estado haciendo en mi laboratorio
es estudiar a estos especialistas sensoriales, los murciélagos,
y hemos analizado los genes que causan ceguera
cuando tienen un defecto,
genes que causan sordera cuando tienen un defecto,
y ahora podemos predecir qué lugares tienen la mayor probabilidad de causar enfermedades.
Entonces los murciélagos son importantes para nuestra salud,
para tener un mejor entendimiento de cómo funciona nuestro genoma.
Entonces aquí es donde estamos ahora,
pero ¿qué hay del futuro?
¿Y la longevidad?
Aquí es a donde vamos a ir, y como dije antes,
de verdad creo que el secreto de la eterna juventud
está en el genoma del murciélago.
Entonces, ¿por qué deberíamos estar interesados en el envejecimiento?
Bueno, la verdad, esta es una imagen del siglo XVI
de la fuente de la juventud. El envejecimiento es considerado
uno de los aspectos más familiares pero menos
entendidos de la biología, y la verdad,
desde el principio de la civilización los humanos han tratado de evitarlo.
Pero vamos a tener que entenderlo un poco mejor.
Solo en Europa, en 2050, va a haber
un 70% de incremento de individuos mayores de 65,
y un 170% de incremento de individuos mayores de 80.
Cuando envejecemos, nos deterioramos, y esta deterioración
causa problemas en nuestra sociedad, entonces tenemos que enfrentarla.
Entonces, ¿cómo podría el secreto de la eterna juventud
estar en el genoma de un murciélago? ¿Alguien quiere
adivinar cuánto tiempo podría vivir este murciélago?
Quién --levanten sus manos-- ¿quién dice 2 años?
¿Nadie? ¿Uno? ¿Qué tal 10 años?
¿Algunos? ¿Qué tal 30?
¿Qué tal 40? Bueno, la respuesta es muy variada.
Este murciélago es "myotis brandtii". Es el murciélago que más vive.
Ha vivido hasta 42 años,
y hoy sigue vivo en el medio silvestre.
Pero ¿qué es tan impresionante de esto?
Bueno, normalmente, en los mamíferos hay una relación
entre el tamaño corporal, velocidad del metabolismo,
y cuánto puedes vivir, y puedes predecir
cuanto puede vivir un mamífero por su masa corporal.
Normalmente, los mamíferos pequeños viven rápido, mueren jóvenes.
Piensen en un ratón. Pero los murciélagos son muy diferentes.
Como pueden ver en esta gráfica, en azul,
estos son todos los otros mamíferos, pero los murciélagos
pueden vivir hasta nueve veces más de lo esperado
a pesar de tener una velocidad metabólica muy, muy alta,
y la pregunta es: ¿cómo pueden hacer eso?
Hay 19 especies de mamíferos que viven más
de lo esperado, dada su masa corporal, que los humanos,
y 18 de esas son murciélagos.
Entonces, deben tener algo en su ADN
que les permite lidiar con el estrés metabólico,
particularmente de volar. Usan 3 veces más energía
que un mamífero del mismo tamaño,
pero no parecen sufrir las consecuencias o los efectos.
Entonces ahora, en mi laboratorio, estamos combinando
lo más avanzado en el campo de biología de murciélagos, saliendo y atrapando
los murciélagos que han vivido mucho, con la más reciente,
tecnología molecular moderna para entender mejor
qué es lo que ellos hacen para impedir envejecer como nosotros.
Y ojalá en los próximos 5 años, les pueda dar una charla TED sobre eso.
El envejecimiento es un gran problema para la humanidad,
y yo creo que estudiando a los murciélagos, podemos descubrir
los mecanismos moleculares que les permitan a los mamíferos
alcanzar una longevidad extraordinaria. Si descubrimos
qué es lo que están haciendo, tal vez a través de terapias genéticas,
podamos permitirnos hacer lo mismo.
Potencialmente, esto significa que podríamos detener el envejecimiento y quizá hasta revertirlo.
Solo imaginen cómo sería eso.
Entonces realmente, yo no creo que deberíamos estar pensando en ellos
como demonios voladores de la noche, sino más como nuestros súper héroes.
Y la realidad es que los murciélagos nos pueden traer muchos beneficios
si solo buscáramos en el lugar adecuado. Son buenos para nuestro ecosistema,
nos permiten entender cómo funciona nuestro genoma,
y potencialmente guardan el secreto de la eterna juventud.
Entonces esta noche, cuando salgan de aquí y miren para arriba
en los cielos de la noche, y vean a este hermoso mamífero volador,
quiero que sonrían. Gracias. (Aplausos)